hey everyone and welcome to another HD
tutorial in this one I'll be showing you
guys how to zoom in and take screenshots
of your um of your computer screen
um right now I'm using a 17 inch laptop
but say I have a certain maybe I'm in
the calculator and I got a weird funky
number nothing special but I want to
take a screenshot of it while there are
several ways uh built into Windows just
so that I can actually do this
the first way is to go to your start
menu and type uh snip
snip and hit enter this will bring up so
would you like to add it to your quick
launch bar I'll just hit no but it says
to drag the cursor around the area you
want to capture so I'm just going to
click and drag it's very intuitive
bam and it open up in the Snipping Tool
and that is exactly the screenshot that
I just took and of course you can see
it's still in the background I'll exit
out so this is the built-in Windows
Vista Snipping Tool I can hit new at any
time to take a new snip
which I will just do random little snip
of my rocket dock if I want to show you
guys that
um I can go to file and say a new snip I
can save this as a JPEG or an image I
can also send this as an email
attachment and I can exit out I can copy
the image and paste it into say
Microsoft's word or paint if I wanted to
edit it I can also edit this in gamper
Photoshop
um under Tools there's a a pen and a
highlighter tool which is quite useful
for maybe circling something within your
screenshot and you can also customize
the thickness of and the color of your
pen
also under Tools there's an eraser and a
highlighter I'll show you the Eraser
real quick all you have to do if you
have a pen Mark say I was trying to
Circle show you guys something here
of course that's not exactly accurate
but that would be that would come under
me um using my customizing tool for the
pen so now the Eraser all I have to do
is just hover right over it and wow it's
not working very well but um
that it would be just easy to erase it
real quick so um I'm going to take a new
snip right now and just actually I'm
going to do a larger snip than I would
actually need this comes in handy when
you actually want to edit your snip
um I'll go to edit and copy
and I'm going to open up paint
and I'm going to when the paint is open
go Ctrl V to actually paste it so now
you can see I have the snip in here I
can crop it I can make it smaller I can
take a certain part out and remove it
Etc so this is a really nice feature
that they've built into Windows Vista
that allows you to take screenshots now
this is probably the best feature
because it allows you to actually take
a particular image the next thing you
can do is to actually hit the print
screen button on your keyboard which
might be abbreviated PRT space SC
basically when you click this when you
hit this button
bam I've hit the button now I'll open up
paint again
and I will just go Ctrl V and paste that
image and there you see my desktop ready
for me to edit whatever I have to do if
I want to crop it if I want to open it
in [ __ ] I can do all these things and
edit my desktop so that is basically two
versions of how to take screenshots in
Windows Vista so I hope you found this
tutorial helpful if you have any other
suggestions then go ahead and subscribe
and just send me a message and I'll get
to it as soon as I can thanks for
watching peace